I hope you didn't just come for the
pizza because pizza is out and content
is on some people definitely came for
the content so my name is Gregor I'm a
smart nation fellow I always like to
highlight the nation is already smart
I'm just a fellow helping out wherever I
can so makes for a very nice title and
I've worked with Gulf tech work with
Charo and many other folks on our
strategy architecture in general today
though I don't talk so much about just
what we do as the government there's
plenty of cool things like anything
mentioned but I want to take sort of
slightly different lenses sort of what
does cloud actually mean and the reason
that's interesting is because if you ask
anybody today whether they going to the
cloud the answer is of course yes of
course everybody's going to the cloud
and people don't just go to the cloud
like normal these days at the minimum
you gonna have multi cloud right because
come on
it is like otherwise it's just for
beginners and look oh sorry I forgot one
day there's one more right so well so if
you go cloud at least we do multi cloud
because otherwise it's just for children
and you know what what are we going
multi cloud and a minimum we are going
to be cloud native right come on how can
you be not cloud native all you need to
do is implement these things this is the
cloud native landscape right I see AWS
here at least one thing I'd recognize
right yeah you know this is all you need
to do and then somehow you magically
become cloud native hell yeah all right
and you're gonna be so cloud native that
you don't even have time for cloud
immigrants anymore right because it's
like you're gonna be so cloud native
that's all you're gonna have right
fantastic so everybody's in the cloud
everybody's going about a cloud
everybody's cloud native sounds
fantastic so have a really interesting
study that I found why people actually
go to the cloud right it almost seems
like superfluous to even ask but why do
people go to the cloud well the reasons
are fairly straightforward we want to
save money all right we want to improve
uptime rhinock Laos you have
availability zones all these kind of
things right you can make your systems
around
well we want to speed things up like he
want to deliver and deploy software
faster and of course you want to somehow
transform your IT there's a few more
reasons though which is well the
developers just went to the cloud we
couldn't really know this right so we
went to the cloud without planning and
there's another reason it's actually
good for my resume and if anybody
believes the statistic be assured this
is completely made-up on the other hand
it's a fairly good reflection of reality
and the research company you know
there's these research companies that
have nice acronyms like Dora is one like
the DevOps research an assessment well
this comes from the cloud research and
prognosis ahem so that's where this
research comes from
however this matches relative reality
fairly well and one of my pet peeves is
I like to learn about Architecture from
real life so let's put the cloud thing
aside and let's look at real life what
all our hybrid multi cloud native thing
looks like and it looks very much like
these things all right very nice shiny
objects who wants one why do certainly
give me all three right this is multi
hybrid cloud native all right there now
these things have a name they called
wishes right these are things that you
would like to have right that you're
wishing for but you're more likely than
not that you don't really have now that
is a little bit sad so if you want to
make some of your wishes come true you
need to have some concrete goals like
getting a good education saving some
money right things become a little bit
more concrete like the boat and the
Ferrari are not gonna materialize right
until you have some goals along the
lines now of course these goals also
don't materialize you know out of
nowhere so you need to do something so
you can study you can inherit other
people have a different strategy is
which is winning the lottery and then
there's people who sort of think they're
gonna rob a bank but to be honest that
is unlikely to get you either to your
goals
nor to your wishes you're gonna live in
a very big house with many rooms but
that's called prison
that's not a house you wanted so if you
want your wishes
you better have clear goals and a clear
strategy and the reason I'm making this
little detour is because I do see a lot
of wishing in cloud a lot of buzzwords a
lot of shiny objects right we didn't
quite get to the cloud in the first
place but at least next time it's gonna
be hybrid multi something cloud right so
the the wishes having wishes is
relatively easy right now since we're
learning from reality there's another
hard lesson reality is you know life
isn't a hundred percent fair so there's
another hard lesson which is buying
these is not going to make you that guy
all right so you know just like the
sneakers don't make you the coolest
repre dude on the planet just
provisioning something the cloud is also
not gonna make you digital transformed
automatically this is called marketing
and there's always a small gap between
marketing and reality right
I say marketing is a great thing as long
as you don't believe everything you hear
right so you know more bad news so now
that we're all depressed right we had
all these fantastic wishes about the
cloud and we thought it gonna be like
super cool right mr. rapper dude big
house big car big boat right that didn't
quite happen so now it's time to
actually look back at cloud and have a
different point of view
fewer buzz words but a bit more thought
provoking the first one that I like to
highlight is when people think about
cloud and embarking on a cloud journey
they tend to look at well what does
cloud bring me on the first thing they
see servers network storage right they
see equipment infrastructure and that's
what you do right the first thing you do
on on 8 is deploy some ec2 instance
right or something right that's how you
start so the way they go on the
organization is they look first at
servers and network and storage now the
reality is nobody wants to serve right
people want to run applications servers
are known as those things they are that
lotta money consumed a lot of energy
right to produce a lot of heat and now
obsolete in three years
that's a server nobody wants right so on
the end people want to deploy
applications and that's why if you see
cloud as an infrastructure topic you
probably made the first major mistake
right it's not about infrastructure it's
about changing the way you build and
deploy applications so that's first
lesson right it looks like
infrastructure but if all that cloud was
was another kind of data center it
wouldn't be half as exciting right
nobody would be talking about it we have
outsourced data centers for decades
right so cloud is a different lifestyle
not a replacement for your data center
second one is when we talk about
enterprise cloud right so enterprise
wants to go on the cloud or any large
organization now even I would include us
there are sort of a few things you need
to keep in mind you can't just run off
with a credit card and everybody just
like go provision service left right and
center right that will not work so you
need a few things you need generally
onboarding process some billing approval
right who's going to the cloud who's
gonna pay for it what cost sentry have
it makes a lot of sense right you will
need some sort of hybrid approach right
you're not gonna be able to move
everything into the cloud overnight some
stuff will stay on premises for us as
the government particularly true right
well we're not so keen to share Lea our
cloud which was like anybody else right
so what do people do they get a virtual
private cloud right the cloud providers
offer that right and then usually
there's some stuff to do still
internally like open firewalls and some
other things right you just carry a
little bit more weight with you that you
need to take care of when you go to the
cloud and lastly IT departments like
ours like gov tech we need to recover
our cost right building this enterprise
cloud these things on top of the public
cloud costs some money right so somehow
we need to recover that from our
customers now this all sounds entirely
reasonable but there's one catch as many
of you know the NIST like the the
National Institute of Standards and
Technology has published five properties
of what a class
yes on this program for many years right
it's on demand self-service Road network
access resource pooling rapid elasticity
and measured service now the unfortunate
result is if you look at the things on
the left hand side they unfortunately
exactly the opposite of the right hand
side I had the onboarding process took
your rapid self-service away the hybrid
approach right you network just isn't
the same as the internet right your
private cloud isn't as big as the whole
cloud right the service requests make
the scanning a little bit bit slow and
harder and you know the cost recovery
doesn't make it a measured service
because somehow you need to have a
baseline cost so the sad thing is that
in the end if you follow this approach
you lose the label right this is no
longer a cloud so this makes bringing
cloud to enterprise ever more
interesting right and we are part of
this journey right we're trying to be
look at smarter than this right because
this is sort of the classic pitfall to
fall into we take the cloud we get all
the buzzwords and then we wrap it in
enterprise right and all the the
abilities go away please don't do that
now the answer to that is you need to
rethink and rework the way you IT works
and if you layer this just copy paste on
your existing IT you don't get a cloud
you get another data center and no CIO
ever needed another data center right so
the only way out of this is you need to
rethink how your IT functions otherwise
you will do exactly this and that's very
dangerous last one is when going to the
cloud they sort of wonder about but what
about the applications which aren't so
cloud native right we have a lot of
commercial off-the-shelf applications
packaged application is a lot of stuff
right how are we gonna get that to the
cloud because it may not run in
containers it's certainly not service
right it might not scale out there's a
third lesson to be learned and the third
lesson is ironic other people's software
is actually a bad deal right most of IT
like we spend like often 60 70 % of our
budgets running other people's software
well there's a great stuff for me
there's I say PE and Oracle financials
and HR systems right and CRM system and
all the kind of stuff right we run this
all but if you think about
it's actually a very bad deal because
you pay for the hardware right you do
all the installation if anything goes
wrong it's your fault right because it
runs on your infrastructure and if you
want a new feature you're gonna wait for
the next feature release because it's
not your software so the hard lesson
here is all that stuff that you have the
short answer is you shouldn't be running
at all right you shouldn't be like
making this container ready etc and we
know the buzzword that stands behind
this answer right this is what
software-as-a-service means right
software-as-a-service means don't run
software that you didn't build use
workday they use some you know cloud CRM
serious cloud integration
you know whether it's Salesforce
whatever this right s ap in the cloud
all their stuff is available so the
vector he is clear the things that you
don't build you have somebody else run
and you run a new cloud stuff that you
build yourself and that's why it's not
about infrastructure but it's all about
application delivery and velocity so
quite different view right nothing to do
with servers as I said nobody wants one
so let's translate that into a strategy
right so we now kind of know what some
of the pitfalls are and have a different
way of thinking about cloud now that
alone doesn't make a strategy we have
some goals right but we still need a
strategy remember we have like four
possible strategies so in our case the
one that always comes up it's multi
clout everybody talks about Martic lot
because you don't want to be locked in
maybe some cloud provider has a nicer
feature reinvent this going on this week
or last week right so there's like 40
new AWS features and the next equivalent
from the other cloud providers will come
well now when I look at as an architect
and this is actually a blog post from
from my website here's I see very
different flavors of multi-cloud the one
that nobody wants to really admit is bug
you randomly have some stuff in one
cloud and you have randomly other things
in the other cloud this is particularly
true in the pillar my developers went in
the cloud already and nobody noticed
right because they go wherever they
think it's best when I see a lot when I
I worked at Google cloud for a little
while I saw this quite a bit right a lot
of people came to Google for the
analytics like bigquery and stuff like
that but to be honest
vm's and compute and stuff was still on
AWS because just wait wäôre yer to
market right so you segment right do you
have some things like a workload normal
compute you have here and then maybe
data analytics machine learning you have
there may be some other things you have
an asteroid class right big step ahead
or you can give people a choice so
forever application they have you can
say I allow you to go to this cloud in
this gap
that's how GCC is built because as a
government you know a we like to have an
open mind and B we have a mandate to
have a neutral spread across vendors so
GCC gives you this our government
commercial cloud right you have an
application you want to deploy that on
GCC you can choose you can have AWS you
can have venture you can have GCP right
then you can do more clever things if
you want right you can tell people who I
can deploy here and I can deploy there
at the same time at that point I would
ask you though be careful to know why
you're doing this so for example you
might want to do this for resilience
purposes right fair enough right but you
need to have a good idea why you're
doing it and the last one is sort of the
Nirvana right well you just move stuff
to the cloud and it sort of magically
shifts left and right and there's always
this scenario about oh if this cloud
provider raises the prices right I just
take my stuff and drag and drop it to
the other cloud and I tell them how see
alright I got you right so remember
there's remember the wishes everybody's
wishing for this but most people are
actually here right they have random
stuff and random places so what I'm
trying to say is these things are not
black or white right and having an
architectural thought about it and
understanding what the difference of
patterns or or reference architectures
are and choosing wisely like first this
is actually a great thing we have a few
systems where we might want to this and
to be honest this is kind of rare right
it's like it's rare that we need to sort
of shift applications willy-nilly from
one cloud to another it looks good on
paper but in reality not very much
needed right those are the shiny the
shiny Ferraris that you're probably not
actually gonna get so very very
different look at at multi cloud right
nice buzzwords you need to check reality
what you actually need what brings you
value and what kind of architecture
stands behind it
he'll some of the trade-offs are I
probably bit much text to read on but
you know message here's none of these
are free one of the reasons we don't go
to shiny shiny object land is because
this has some advantage advantages right
it's like complexity right it's just a
lot of moving parts that you need to
manage and you know what you might not
be locked into a specific cloud but now
you locked yourself into a multi cloud
framework now is that better than being
locked into one cloud provider now
you're locked into somebody else's
multi-cloud abstraction complexity layer
right I don't think you've got much
better off right so you need to make
these conscious decisions all of these
have advantages right and all of these
have some disadvantages that's the
business of architecture that's a look
next password hybrid cloud and hybrid
cloud means some stuff goes some stuff
stays right you move some stuff in the
cloud some stuff stays some promise now
you don't need to be you know sort of a
PhD in a cloud strategy to know what
that the next question is well what goes
and what stays right and again from an
architecture point of view many many
many choices right you can move the
front an hour and keep the back end on
very popular you can also put the new
things out because they're more likely
to be cloud native with air quotes right
and you keep the old things on-premise
right but you can also some people want
to test the water they put some
non-critical systems out and keep the
cards right and the list goes on right
for us by data classification right so
for example we don't put secret things
in the public cloud right they stay
where they belong
things that may be restricted our okay
to go some people are happier to stay on
premise unless they need to do a
disaster recovery and then they happy to
run in the cloud so you can slice many
many different ways so again have a
whole blog post about this right the
word is there's a lot of thought behind
these buzzwords right so rather than
chasing buzzwords
what we should do is actually look at
these carefully and say well which one
can we store maybe we do a little bit of
this we do a little bit of this and that
makes the difference between buzzwords
and cloud strategy all right that's the
difference between a wish and having a
strategy how to make the vicious become
reality
cost was one of the first things in my
faced statistic and of course it's not
that fake everybody wants to save money
right you know IT is great but if you
can do it for less that is even better
and you will save money in the cloud but
you have to be very clear about that
doesn't come free the cost savings have
to be earned well the first cost savings
that you might get and you'll likely get
this by just moving to the cloud you can
shave a little bit of money off slightly
better economies of scale right you get
sort of sustained use discounters a
little bit of money you will be more
safe but it's not gonna be like half or
like 90% off or something but I was like
hell and then Amazon and Google don't
buy the server for 90% less than you do
right they have more efficient
operations but it's not gonna be that
much right then my experience the
biggest one is you optimize what you
have and then once you optimize you can
even get better and make it resilient
and I explain what you mean but what I
mean sorry the first ingredient you need
to do in order to get from on-premise to
cloud there's migration costs so it's
not free both intellectually as well as
from a dollars perspective right
migration cost money don't we need to do
that equation right to be honest most of
the time many times this equation comes
out sort of closer to zero and the
migration cost the applications are not
gonna be some of perfect for the cloud
you're learning new stuff right it's
gonna cost some money so if you break
even or save a little bit we're actually
in pretty good shape
this one though can be a big winner and
there's an ingredient that is often
underestimated as being valuable in the
cloud
and that is transparency like now you're
in the cloud you can see your
utilizations you can see your
applications you can see your workload
you have much much better overview and
you can see all the servers that are not
doing much you can see oversized
infrastructure right you can see
redundant machines machines like orphans
that were left behind that never did
anything in the first place right
transparency in my experience this is
actually that's where the money is right
so a lot of people do this and get
disappointed right and they forget that
actually here is where the money is and
then of course the next one is
automation
alright and I can I'll explain why
automation is actually such a big
ingredient into savings right when
people think about automation they think
it's about reducing manual labor right
as I go if it's automated you don't need
to anybody to click the buttons that is
totally not the main goal the main goal
of automation is to reduce our overall
operational cost and the way I'll
illustrate this this is a blog post I
wrote for Google cloud right we see we
have saw the classic CIO agenda right
what does IT need to do well nobody
wants to be in the front page of the
newspaper right it's got to be secure
right nobody wants to pay fighty that
isn't actually running and please see us
we said don't spend too much money while
you added yeah when I worked at Google I
would always go to the customers saying
look I have all this cool stuff right I
can bring you automation speed feedback
your machine learning I can bring you
all the cool things and the CEOs
invariably would say hey do you Google
got it that is all really cool but you
know what my world is very different
right they're like I totally get what
you're selling rodeo you're pitching me
right but it's like my world is very
different then now we need to think
about what's the most expensive server
well the moment the answer is relatively
easy the most expensive server is the
one that's not doing anything and you
know what if you get it foots rent for
20% cheaper it's still the most
expensive server right so now don't try
to you know get 20% off your servers
figure out which servers and do anything
so what are the servers they're not
doing anything
most people's data centers are full of
servers that aren't doing anything and
the reason is very simple
availability how do you buy yourself
availability of warm standby right you
have redundancy that's the way you get
availability oh now what is redundancy
redundancy is most of the time unless
you have a fancy active active you know
whatever right most of the time
redundancy is you have a server that's
not doing anything so what's you're
realizing is that actually in the
classic IT we believe that cost and
availability oppose each other right the
more highly available I need to be the
more money I need to spend and we
totally forget that the real
all the levers on the left because if I
can provision new instances near
instantly I don't need all those warm
standbys right you have this fully
containerize right maybe I run three
instances one dies right i spool up
another one if I know quick enough right
if it's fully automated and I have fast
deployment I can be cheaper and more
resilient and that's why rethinking the
way cloud words that's the way you save
the money because otherwise you always
stuck in your own equation right and
that's why in the previous slide I
showed right having the automation
that's the money saver right everything
else is sort of a little bit of
fine-tuning and a lot of folks get this
dis harmed or disappointed early so they
never actually get there and then they
never get the full benefit off the cloud
and that's actually actually kind of
sound so my role is architect is how
people think about this in different
ways last one I have is locking I
alluded to this before and people want
to go to the cloud and then that's like
oh but I'm gonna be locked in like these
days like the press everything is for I
need to be hybrid multi everything avoid
the locking as always lock if things are
not black or white and lock-in is also
not like Hawaii the way you think about
locking what is locking locking is
something that gives you a high
switching cost right if you want to get
out it's not that easy you'll pay a
little bit of money but that's not the
only dimension is lock-in can also give
you benefits or vice versa avoiding
lock-in is gonna cost you so you need to
see of course if I have a benefit for
low switching costs that is really nice
right but I might be happy to be locked
into something right if I get the
benefit agian Cockcroft has a great talk
opener that he gives he asks everybody
who is worried about locking all the
hands go up and then he says who is
married and all the same hands go up and
he's like well alright
yeah the world isn't so black or white
right so you can be happily locked in
I'm a little bit more devious than that
and I say who has an iPhone well I see
one right there because my example this
you
so happily locked in actually some
people sometimes more locked into they i
from them there's a statistic when
people wake up what percentage of people
reaches for the phone first as opposed
to their partner and the number is
scarily high so so so they're the Apple
login is very real now here's the one
way you don't want to be right but you
don't get a utility but you have high
switching cost so that's usually called
mobile contracts sorry hope hopefully
nobody here I picked us examples to be a
little bit politically correct right
right this is your 24 month contract
ahem yeah then you get nothing then down
here where it's like little utility but
switching that's like you adapters
duplex whatever I it is like you know
anytime you get a new one down here is a
little bit harder the best I could come
up with is some chat applications where
you're not as locked in because mostly
they use your address book so when you
switch to write the address book is
still there your friends might not be
there but that's a different story
but from a technical perspective right
you can switch between most messaging
apps and your contacts right here
numbers transport over but it's
unfortunately a little bit rare we have
things in this category this is totally
fine if you get the value out of it just
use it another way to look at this is
basically avoiding locking is basically
investing upfront to avoid a future
liability right here you're paying more
now to switch more easily in the future
there's a couple of things you need to
be very careful about is you need to
consider the total cost right because
you're spending money right now to avoid
something in the future
we call this reducing the cost of
uncertainty right that's the thing you
can do like buying insurance is a good
thing generally work for a large
insurance company before right buying
insurance is reducing the cost of
uncertainty you don't know what's gonna
come so you rather pay now then they are
pay big time in case something happens
now in ID though you need to see how
much it's gonna cost you so let's say
you want to make your stuff portable
across clouds all right well it's gonna
cost you some money you need to learn
company it is deploy something so I do
some stuff let's say it's not even that
expensive let's say it costs you like a
couple of person weeks or something
I'd say it cost you like $20,000 or
something I was like would be actually
very very no I would say right what is
the likelihood you're gonna switch like
in the foreseeable future over the
lifetime of your modern app modern apps
live like three four five years at best
let's say three years so what are the
chance you're gonna switch like 5% 10%
all right if I can't how do I say let's
say it's it's it's from 5% right so one
out of twenty so if I spend $20,000 now
I would need to have a migration cost of
$400,000 right times 20 to make that
breakeven now that would be a high
migration Costra it was like it's not
gonna cost me four hundred thousand
dollars to migrate my application or
maybe cost me forty thousand maybe worst
case it cost me a hundred thousand right
so let's say it costs me hundred
thousand dollars to migrate my
application for Nabel over the years to
Azure right if the chance I need to do
it is one out of twenty that is an
effective cost of $5,000 for $5,000 I'm
not gonna build myself a hybrid sauna
magic cloud
automated kind of provisioning moving
thing no way right if somebody will do
that for $5,000 please talk to me later
I'll be happy to retain your services
right right so be careful right as
architects we tend to be over excited
about investing now to avert things in
the future we feel we always need to
have the option but we forget the cost
of it so I highlighted the cost in terms
of dollars but there is a much worse
cost because at the end dollars kind of
sucks but you know what money you can
usually find somewhere there's too much
worst cost the one is complexity right
and the reason usually things don't move
quickly or they break is complexity and
so complexity is very expensive for us
because that's where a lot of the
problems come from and the second one is
equally nasty I go to the cloud because
the cloud has all these managed services
I can get RDS I can get bigquery I can
get Aurora I can go down I'm gonna be
and I can get all this cool stuff it's
fully managed for me well if I want to
be fully portable then that kind of goes
out the window right because three of my
stuff runs on or around woody B and I
moved
to injure it doesn't work that well
right now I need to do something right
so what people do is they actually deny
themselves the main reason they went to
the cloud in the first place right
because you want to have access to these
managed services and now you're saying
oh but I don't like to be logged in so
I'm not gonna use any of these managed
services that makes little sense right
so make sure the equation comes out for
you right
don't be stupid maybe you abstract some
things but don't try to achieve zero
switching costs for something that maybe
has a 5% chance of actually occurring
right it might be fun from a technical
perspective but this is the cost curve
free all right it's definitely not the
minimum me if you do that you much
rather want to be there well with that
that's probably all I have and I hope I
could move a little bit from the next
time somebody says are you going to the
cloud right you can say yes but I know
why I'm going I have clear goals I have
a strategy behind it and I have an
architectural mindset how I'm gonna do
that so thank you very much
[Applause]
I thought I talked enough that all right
somebody please last question the non
golfers you can get a t-shirt any time
oh yes and I - oh sorry I get this I'm
preaching to the church
my question is to all of us in this
message all expected we go back to our
CIOs and our senior management system
trans asylum not had a chance to the
city to hear this so I have like three
answers the first answers you should
have brought them a lot right so I mean
jokes aside right I mean there's the
sale they are see how its need to hear
this the second one is depending who it
is we might even go visit them right we
have a mandate ultimately to her to help
people understand but the third answer
is I find is that management can
understand this quite easily the biggest
problem we have now people don't become
upper management by not being very smart
of not learning new things yeah that
doesn't work right the challenge they
often have is they grew up with a
different set of technologies and a
different set of base assumptions and
when we come in and all we do is babble
acronyms right like like clown native
hybrid you know cloak
yeah multi-tenant Lila Lila right and
then everything is so I used to say that
business complaints about IT because we
sound like we speaking Greek and you
know what now we're actually speaking
Greek right everything is kubernetes
Prometheus is T all right it is actually
Greek right
so business has a point right so but
more seriously right so if you come in
with a shiny object acronyms they will
not listen and you know what they
actually probably right if you come in
with explaining the mechanisms behind it
which admittedly yeah I compress this a
little bit but what I try to do is show
the mechanisms behind it
they will most of the time understand my
job at Google cloud was busy I talk with
CEOs and see hours all the time and the
reason I came up with some of these
models and this concept was that you
know I can convey this to them second
one is harder but also doable requires
patience you need to understand that
they grew up with different assumptions
give you a great example when I wasn't
aliens very very smart guy board member
yeah like top top top making millions of
euros right super successful super smart
guy and he came to me and he said I
don't like scaling out mic if he says
like scale out architectures are no good
I'm like how can this be right all we do
is elastic scale out resilient right
that's like sort of our Bible if you
want a huge analogy and this super
intelligent man basically says yeah I
don't believe in that so what you need
to understand there is you need to
reverse engineer so don't assume they're
up there they're dumb or don't know or
don't listen it means they have learned
something in made assumptions that were
true at some point but are no longer
true in this case the answer would
relatively simple in the old days
scaling out carried a lot of overhead
right because you couldn't scale up that
quickly anyway and do be honest nothing
scales linearly right twice as many
servers don't give you twice the
performance so he saw that as a waste of
money right I can buy a twice as big
server and probably I get almost double
the performance versus if I buy two
servers hey I need load balancers and
synchronizes and other stuff and bi will
not get double the performance so he was
looking at from an efficiency
perspective not from a scale perspective
and you have to admit if you look from a
pure efficiency perspective scaling out
is less efficient is right the answer
that we would have is yeah but it
doesn't matter now that is a big jump
right we know it doesn't matter
so what you will find is they have
learned things and made assumptions
based on the Hat
that we're absolutely correct and are
sometimes still correct but no longer
valid or applicable and my tip there is
you need to reverse engineer where these
kind of beliefs come from right
that requires some patience or I give
you another classic example people have
learned that speed and quality or poses
each other all right people are saying
when you hurry up me our quality goes
down we know that is not exactly true
because all our DevOps automation kind
of stuff right does miracles but they
don't know that right so if you're
talking to somebody who believes that
quality and speed oppose each other and
you're gonna pitch my sort of continuous
delivery DevOps kind of stuff that's
gonna be a very hard sell because if
they hit all the speed you're pitching
right it's gonna translate into lower
quality right so you need to speak the
language of the folks you talk to and
reverse engineer their assumptions and
then you need to basically prove to them
or show to them why the world has
changed so much because the tough part
is most of the time they have living
proof for their assumptions like they
made a change and everybody stayed up
three nights straight or fix it right or
they rushed the project right and they
cut QA because in the old days you know
what they did way was always at the end
so if you cut the project by a month QA
took the hit and you know what the
quality was actually lower so they have
living proof for their beliefs
so you need to be patient and basically
make one step back before you can take
two steps forward all right so one don't
cover the passwords right explain to
people they will understand they're
smart folks and number two if somehow
it's not connecting it's not because
they're not listening it is because they
have some belief stuck somewhere right
that they learn that you need to get
them to unlearn that's that's what I do
most of the time right that was my job
so I I can happily say can be done right
not easy but it can be done I think
we're probably only running one more
question right okay one more yes
how engineer ah yeah I call it debugging
and troubleshooting we engineers are
very good at this right we see a system
which doesn't do what we want right and
we need to find where it's falsely
programmed so all jokes aside the
exercise is a little bit like that right
you're observing something where the
system is not the system in this case is
your organization on your management
right it's not behaving the way you want
we have a name for that that's called a
bug right if our system doesn't do what
we thought it does it has a bug right so
with that is you need to basically
reverse engineer the best there's two
good techniques the one technique we use
way too little is ask them ask them why
do you think that is like honestly right
when somebody says like oh I don't
believe in scale-up that's surprising
what why do you think that is that's how
I found out I said like why do you think
that would be nice I Wally I never
scales linearly and I said and I'm like
I'm like oh my god yeah he's right but
he's also wrong right so so ask is the
easy one the other one is the list of
beliefs that classic IT has is not
infinitely long so there's a cheat sheet
all right and now now be a little bit
self-serving because I have a book here
which I have on my website there is a
new chapter which is actually in the
book I'm working on updating my book and
one of the chapters it's gonna come out
with a Riley in some time next year
there will be a chapter where your basic
get a you get a cheat list alright it's
not a classic things that people believe
like people believe you can solve
everything with more money and more
people you know people believe that your
quality or pose of speed the list is not
infinitely long so having a cheat sheet
goes a long way good with that I think
we have a lot more exciting stuff thanks
for listening
[Applause]